bismillah hamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you thank you for coming
back to another episode of the Dean show
every week we're here Wednesday's
midnight if you're up tune in to the
Dean show can TV 36 if you can't make it
midnight Wednesday's the next day two to
three thursdays so that's if you're in
chicago otherwise all over the globe
people are tuning in at the Dean show
com that's where you can see our shows
today we're going to be talking about
boys girls men women marriage hot topic
with my next guest baba ali here on the
day show don't go nowhere love there's
only one Mohammed is His Messenger of
Allah
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice assalamu
alaikum welcome Sam Tula please be on to
you brother please be upon to you too
how are you good how are you you're back
again yes I'm back again just like I
just saw you it just feels like a few
minutes ago right man we're here I'm
excited that you here we're going to be
talking about people can go to the Dean
shoulder common we got to talk about how
you actually came to this beautiful way
of life the way of life of all the
messengers that submission is written to
God alone and not his creation but in
this show we're going to be talking
about something that is on the minds of
the people you got this yearning you got
this feeling you want to be with the
opposite gender man wants to be with
woman woman wants to be with man I mean
now and they end up doing things that
aren't according to how the Creator
wants them to do it now you have some
experience I mean we live in America and
some things just become normal you know
I'm going to see Sally and Betty and
we're just dating and then you know we
test drive and we have a good time and
then people get heartbroken you know so
let's let's just flow with this tell us
you know what is your experience and
with this whole you know and it's become
something as prevalent now amongst the
Muslims yeah unfortunately these days
you see a lot of Muslims the the parents
have made marriage very difficult for
them not to use other parents I will say
the culture that the parents have
implemented on them actually if you look
at Islam it's all made marriage very
easy it's a very easy process and very
easy to go through it unfortunately our
culture many of the people from the
Middle East have this culture that they
implemented and force upon their
children they have nothing through this
song actually most of them in conflicts
with Islam has made a marriage very
difficult for the young people so now
they're resorting to dating and
resorting to doing all these type of
prohibited acts under right under the
noses of parents and every parent is
like know what my son my doctor they're
not doing it yeah but they're usually
the last people to find out it's
someone's son and daughter
and most likely it may be yours so this
thing is I mean with with when you live
in Islam is very simple you need the
Guardian your father or someone there to
say okay because they want to see who
this guy is yeah obviously or some bum
come in the house and he's maybe a crook
maybe this dad the man kind of sniff it
out right yeah Hika Smith is that hell
away yeah you know guys can tell what
the other guys are trying to con my
sister wants trick my sister though it
isn't natural but no matter what
religion you are you know the the father
he's a protective of his daughter you
know I don't want some guy been just I'm
holding this diamond to my hand for the
last 18 to 20 years of her life and now
you're not going to door just want a the
diamond on my head I've been protecting
this thing I'm actually I hand over to
anybody yeah I wasn't what's up who are
you what's your story are you trying
trickered you can try to cozen over I'm
gonna get emotional cry cry and say uh
oh you're lovey dovey Noah I must see
who you are as a person and sometimes
guys can see stuff that other guys that
other girls can may not see ya and then
two witnesses two witnesses so they can
say there's evidence of saying okay
these two people they did say it the day
this person wants this person this
person was this person here and then
let's have a party is ever a hello party
yeah hello party that's it is done
that's the only 50,000 notice if you got
noise go chandelier but people ready
okay we're gonna marry cool it's just an
easy marriage but these days parents
make these difficult conditions these
obstacles is these loops you have to
jump through just to get married you
have parents say okay I want a
fifty-thousand-dollar wedding $50,000 a
house in snow barrier yeah I mean with
the rate that people are getting
divorced you can get married now and
you're still paying for it and get
divorced and you're still paying for
your marriage you know it's unfortunate
it is a lot of time to do a show like to
show to just to be the better to keep up
with the Joneses to be better than the
next person say okay look our wedding
was 50,000 or whether it was a hundred
thousand I already was three it's
amazing and these kids emotionally ask
the kids they don't know they don't even
want it there was something easy and
simple they just want to be with the
person
that they found for the rest of their
life not to come back with the little
debt letter says are you in debt for
next 10 years realizing as 20,000 go for
that one it just had one night four
hours yeah doesn't make sense but it's
la makes it easy but the people make it
hard make it difficult yes tell us now
what I mean what advice can we give to
the youth out there also i mean some
parents are making it difficult but you
know to be real some parents aren't some
parents really are doing things right
but the you some of them i just caught
up in society you know and you know
going to the nightclubs you know the
guys got a woman and he's like coming to
islam but still he can't let go this
girl from the past you came in and your
story that you talked and you came full
force you left yes this girlfriend you
had before because you love the creator
and you wanted to do what he wanted you
to do you didn't want to I want dessert
I want you to think is the right way
yeah there's different ways of doing
things there's a wrong way in the right
way you want to make business do it but
doing a way without cheating people you
want to be with the girl do it but
accept that responsibility it says look
I will take care of you for now on I
will feed you provide for your clothes
you take care take care of your motion
use your your physical needs every need
to G I'm here to I'm here for you not
here I'm here to spend one night with
you in the next day with next person the
next day with one person this girls
pregnant and next thing you know your
baby mamas left and right yeah that's
not that's not that's a broken society
and this society has many many broken
pieces to it in a love it has to do with
marriage before sex I've marriage before
sex before marriage so getting myself
all confused but yeah it's it's it's sad
and this is a lot of Muslim eating okay
my daughter she went to an islamic
school she wears a job and none of this
stuff is happening she doesn't desire
boys she desires boys after her PhD no
that's not reality reality is at a
certain age men desire women and women
desire men and our creator made us and
put our instincts inside of us and nose
and gives a prescription just like a
doctor gives a prescription and says
this is the way to do it and this is
will give you success and you go the
other way you'll give you failure we're
here just giving some real advice I mean
we're not two shakes we don't have you
know no just normal people we you know
experience a lot of things live in the
society so we can keep it real we can
give some real advice brother came up to
me I want to see what advice would you
give this brother he's committed to
trying to change himself yeah he's going
after the knowledge that's going to help
to change him but he says you know what
I just can't give this up I can't give
up dating these women it's hard what
advice would use a young man strong and
this is a hard time he's heaven what are
some of the steps now that you think
that you know from your personal
experiences advice that you can give
this brother you know the whole desire
thing is it's very difficult anyone
who's going to set up here so you know
what just give this up and give this up
that is easier said than done they're
either not being real or they haven't
been through it I had a person can tell
you straight up is very difficult your
desires your heart it's is pulling you
to go after something but if you're
connected to the hereafter and you you
want that paradise more than you want
that girl you reminded this life will
come an end this is it this life is like
a dream and all these things are like
trials and tests for you and if you have
that in the back of your head that helps
you become stronger number two is put
your who you're who are your companions
if a knows a bunch of guys who have a
bunch of girlfriends and you're saying
there as the third wheel of course
you'll be pushing to this yeah but hang
out with people who will follow the same
type of thing and going to keep you
strong do other activities until you
have enough money until resources until
you can get married I play basketball
with my friends I go do all kinds of
stuff when you keep ourselves busy until
we're all prepared enough to have enough
finances to get married you know all all
these things make our factors all these
things are variables you put yourself in
a situation or what I'm not gonna be a
good person I wasn't going to club I'm
just gonna watch they're not gonna rise
you know watching it take these baby
steps you know Shaitaan will pull you
step by step he doesn't scream he
whispers you know what just school spend
time with you you just talk to about
Islam you know now that you're talking
to about this love spend a little more
time with her you know maybe she's
lonely a musical only hey you just go
spend some time with her
oh you know what share so much closer
maybe she's hot hope we take off her
clothes and it was hard working I think
you know their place Mobb our clothes I
was no longer and then yeah it's crazy
man is she telling you he's very smart
you bet he's got he's been this is day
one yeah so you a lot of practice uh-huh
lot of practice are you tricking
yourself you're thinking okay maybe
she's there maybe she's in that Club
maybe I can change her yes and you go
I'm going to the club nuts so I can
dance and boogie I am there so I can
teach people his song I want to preach I
will just wait there until somebody
asked me where this summer's but well
I'm right now just dance is confusion
and they really really think to yourself
how are you fooling you only fooling
yourself really only phone yourself and
unfortunately we all fall into this this
just struggle and you really is tough
it's really tough especially in this
society where you have temptation
everywhere from billboards to television
to everything it's everywhere around us
and it's tough but then again paradise
isn't cheap you can't buy yourself in
you can't you can't walk with the PhD or
say oh I'm from this family of that
family you have to earn it and you earn
that by going through the struggles and
bypassing those struggles and this
itself just this marriage and this
desire thing is a struggle that we go in
as our youth it's tough always have to
go through it so you're not alone we
love our brothers we love our sisters we
just want to give them sincere advice we
talked about the brothers now you got
our sisters out there some of them are
falling in the trap you know fall in
finding themselves you know being alone
with a guy and trying to you know
because men they admire they lust and
they look and women you know shirt up to
here then up to here and then fall in
the latest fashions and getting caught
into just being more of a object and
then getting used and abused and maybe
falling for some of the naive tricks
that that guy who's after her you know
yeah have you come across this also it
meant are very smart so for the woman
that are watching and my what religion
are back on your front women you are the
ones are older figure this out by now
but the men will tell you exactly what
you want to hear they have this love
status desire that there's hungry for
it's a hunger
and when you're hungry and you're and
you need to be fed you're gonna say what
you do say what you say so you can get
what you need to get and you don't care
whose hearts you break you don't use it
oh how many so mean they're they're
hungry they're going for his desire and
when you have no guidance and you have
no fear of your Creator you're gonna say
whatever you want to say but he loves me
but he loves me yeah right he doesn't
love you you love something else so this
is a tray I'm a guy I'm gonna tell you
straight up but although he's different
how many girls have said that ask
yourself no I love is like no love ever
in the world we're gonna love each other
forever and ever and ever until we end
up in divorce court two years from now
uh-huh so it's funny all these people
are so in love with WWE how much look at
the divorce rate around the world it's
all fifty percent and those are the
people who decide to stay to get
divorced there's no people that are
connected and they can't get divorced p
and they're married and miserable
they're stuck because of kids they're
stuck because of family issues they're
stuck because of whatever those are
going to count those those stats when we
come there and the people who don't even
live with each other you know they just
decide okay we'll just be separated I'm
like you stay together because of tax
reasons and it's unfortunate
relationship but it does not have the
the universal bond and that's connected
with our values with the right thing and
you know how to treat her and she knows
how to treat you and this is what islam
teaches us by the way how to treat a
woman now what you see on TV now it
doesn't mumbo-jumbo they try to teach
you on television but really the way a
Muslim should treat his wife and his
wife you treat her husband it's it's
it's amazing if you really look into it
it's beautiful like your woman all her
desires must be taken care of for in
Sonic in a relationship man for her
physical needs her emotional needs her
even her sexual needs have to be all
taken care of by the husband on top of
that if she needs helping around the
house you try to help her you get
rewards for that you know these are
encouragement you're encouraged to do
and and islam teaches us the best of you
is who's best to his wife this Ted
teaches a man to like go even beyond of
that compete with other men to be better
for your wife so she
look if we had if we had a society built
on this how much of an impact don't make
and to treat her with honor Islamically
injury died defending her honor it's
tight as a Shahid that me to get
paradise her honor so much protected now
we have all this crazy stuff may just go
around being their wives and all those
domestic violence always crazy stuff
over what over is just crazy it's crazy
how when you go towards culture what it
gives you when you go towards the song
what it gives you and unfortunately we
have too many people towards culture and
not enough people towards Islam that's
what we need we need to learn this way
of life and we need to live it live it
purely and the way it has been
prescribed not according to our desires
are any customs or cultures it's very
simple now what encouragement I mean
some of the benefits from leaving off
following your lusts and desires and
going off and living a life of just you
know from one guy girl to the next where
you come in and and and do something
that's sacred you come together even at
the end I mean if it comes to devore is
not the end of the world but what
encouraged it meant can we give them
that you know what this is a healthier
way of life to live you know even a
divorce issues just product right now
islam allows it yeah but this is the
worst a allowed thing that you can do it
makes according to islamic stew throne
of allah subhan allah sheikh it's the
one that he the least the less he knows
that this isn't it can possibly happen
but it's the last resort i'm fortunate
for many muslims today it's the first
resort you know they jump straight to
tell off which means divorce go straight
to it and as soon as you find the
smallest thing wrong and that is the
guy's girl girls as well i think this is
because we just jump into the hole Oh
Hollywood oh you know prince charming is
going to come and riding his little
horse and he's going to say oh you do
this perfectly my husband he's gonna be
just like Brad Pitt and he's gonna say
the right words at the reitz a time and
blah blah blah yeah and then you come
home realize his socks are on the couch
any scratches OH you guys wait a second
that's not the husband I was looking for
in Hollywood and then he said first mean
thing he said to me
I want a divorce and then next thing
okay I want divorce too now everyone is
single and divorced and like what
happened what makes it work I mean
because I think that's what it is you
get caught up watching too many movies
you're not supposed to be watching first
of all with all with all this junk out
there and you start living this fantasy
yeah and you think that this is what
marriage is is some fantasy fulfilled
yeah what do you think about this it's
it is unfortunately this is movies they
do this silly you can buy their movies
you can watch their movies they do this
so they can fool you to think this is
real life when in reality is not real
life whatsoever marriage life is
complete if and no one prepares you what
to expect for marriage I wish they did
but they don't really prepare you let me
take from the very beginning you always
just from doing the Dean show I'll tell
you straight up on you here in a Dean
show first marriage is hard I'm married
that be married for eight years it's not
easy it's a struggle it's not it's just
easy difficult for me sometimes
difficult for my wife sometimes because
men are very different we think
differently we act differently our
brains are chemicals all our mind is all
completely different you put two
completely different people together and
they're trying to communicate doesn't
always necessarily work out and you
learned you learn to be patient that's
one of the first things you learn in
America pitch patients you learn to work
with another you learn to compromise
sometimes I'm do stuff she like
sometimes she's gonna do stuff I like
all these things you sacrifice but you
do it for the sake of your creator and
say look I might do it you know I'm
arguing with her but I'm good and I know
she did something that was very hurtful
for me but I will forgive her or she may
say I may forgive him and the reason you
forgive with the hope that because in
the somme if you forgive someone you do
it with the hope that Allah will forgive
you for something that you did because
we're all human beings we all make
mistakes we all make errors we have all
so much of our accountable for on the
day judgment so you do that with the
hope that Allah will forgive something
of yours on the day judgment make your
life easier in the hereafter and when
you have this type of mentality and this
type of mindset your marriage and do is
tranquility it can be in your marriage
so on one end here by coming together
to do the right thing man and woman
getting married living life according to
how your Creator wants you live all
about rewards and that's exactly I mean
you're going to have your tests and
trials yes it's not all sugar and roses
on sweets but you get through it and you
get reward you even get rewarded for
having intimate relations but yes you do
that's again you do it correctly yeah if
you do the everything correctly you get
reward for it you get reward for kissing
your wife or sleeping with your wife she
goes reward for it as well you know
you're staying away from the bad things
you trying to stay towards the good
things you're doing things Islamically
the way the Creator wanted you to do
things and by doing things correctly you
get me word for it of course you go
towards the wrong direction you get
punished for it yeah so again by all
that comes back down to accountability
every action we do we're going to be
accountable for everything that we say
even though even this Dean show is being
written for us it'll be accountable for
and this is why it's so important for us
to do things the right way that's the
other side now we talked about all the
rewards here like you said now you get
punished for it you don't want it I mean
Allah the creator of the heavens earth
is the most merciful you stop you repent
he forgives all sins yes except if you
die associating partners with him as
something doesn't forgive so hopefully
Allah guides us all to do the right
thing now over here you're playing games
it's a game isn't it a game you're going
around in circles you know chasing this
person that person I mean you never
satisfy know you never satisfied and you
risk what if you die on that and you get
resurrected in that state that's a
horrible state is calling even if you
survive in this life what if you end up
with some of you have so many diseases
diseases legitimate children yeah what
about that child now huh yeah you ever
try that you're raising and then she's
going to go around sing with more men
who knows you may have kids different
kid from different guys what magical
kind of lifestyle this poor child has to
be raised in yeah it's tough I mean we
leave the society the entire world or
our Muslim Ummah we have OMA which is a
whole other people and is oma is made of
up of countries and these countries are
made up of cities these things may have
communities and these local communities
are made out of just families and the
basic foundation of a family is a
husband
mm-hmm when you break the basic
foundation of a husband and wife and you
have all these divorced people with
little kids and they can't get married
and you make these young guys they can't
get married because the parents are
making it too hard what kind of society
gonna have you have these people that
just frustrated yeah for what it is
another ok how can focus on school who
focus on work and focus on this
naturally man when were supposed to be
together yeah and you gotta get out and
do it she's not gonna come now or he's
not going to just come not you gotta get
out there i do wait am i press traffic
knock on the door there's no prince
charming knock on the door it doesn't
happen you have to go out there and look
for the right person and you should i
were looking for the right girl and it
looked for someone based on their
character not based on the culture now
based on their money now based on the
stuff not based on stuff they had no
choice of which families are going look
for something of their character the way
they look at their creator the way they
look at their values and and hopefully
inshallah she carries the same values
you do and that will keep that person
will keep you in check when you go the
wrong way and you keep her in check when
you go the wrong way you know I mean
these did these are the things are gonna
make possibly a good recipe for a good
marriage now how could we give brothers
like our brother Imran and this brother
Mohammed and his brother so and so Chris
and all the other brothers are Greg and
I just there's so many of sight and
they're all turning married a little
rather read how do you help them I mean
we got to give some kind of solution now
I mean something where they can go
somewhere where the number one best way
to do it if you can go through family
you go through family but if you can't
go through family because family is the
best way they can they know someone who
knows someone it's always better it's
easier if you don't know then there
might be social gatherings if you're
like myself where I come from a family
that doesn't actually practice any type
of religion and you need to find someone
and you look around and like nothing
around me or is working I try going on
the internet and make check out the
matchmaking websites out there they
weren't good they list people like
they're used cars this is the height
this is the weight this is the accessory
this is the blood type and honestly you
don't go to people say hey how much you
weigh you can do a girl you're a big job
of it
but in real life you ask people
questions when you want to learn about
them and so I made up a website called
half our Deen calm and that's basically
a website for trying to help people and
guys and girls to get married and I
asked questions about what you're
looking for in a spouse and and wet wood
and what is that what are you like and I
ask all these questions were going to
family regarding Dean regarding all the
different parts of your life and and
then when you look at someone's profile
tell you you're seventy-five percent
match on religious religious beliefs
twenty-four percent match on personality
ten percent match on character you learn
a lot more about your compatibility
because not every single girl's gonna
match with what I'm looking for in a
wife and I'm not gonna match for a lot
of girls what they're looking for Anna's
bin' some people may look for a shy guy
some guys looking for a guy who's very
assertive and some people are looking
for a guy who's very ambitious different
people are looking for different things
so and we're all different your taste is
very different it's kind of like you go
to a garden there's all these different
types of flowers and they'll have this
different sense you may like roses I may
like some other type of flower doesn't
make one better than the other we're
just trying to find a half our Deen the
whole websites about trying to find you
and that one person is going to match
with you now how does someone I say want
to send my daughter there I can't find
her now what how do I know how do I feel
secure that she's not going to be taking
advantage out because there's a lot of
people out there yet who aren't serious
they might be just trying to sneak
through the cracks there's a couple of
things I try to do and nothing is
guaranteed no matter what website or
even in person you always want to try to
do research and try to find more and
more about the person this website is
here to try to filter out all these
people it's kind of taking their
searching for gold you have all the dirt
there and you're shaking it until you
have a couple pieces of pebbles left and
I now you have to go into detail see how
good quality of gold this is so that's
the website is doing what we're doing
they're trying to filter all these
different people so the questions we ask
will tell your percentage of how you
guys match on different things but on
top of that we let each person has 21
questions that's important to you like
right now we're in Chicago one of the
questions you may ask is are you willing
to move to Chicago if the person says no
then why are you
a talking to the person if you guys if
that's only place you're going to live
yeah or you say what are your what is
your idea about this or what is your
idea about that you can ask these
questions before they even meet the
person and they can answer these
questions before you actually officially
talk and you can and you can go ask to
answer her questions you can ask your
questions you're learning a little more
about each other yeah after all of this
and you go through all these different
profile you so you know what this is a
person I think maybe a possibly match
then you can contact them maybe speak to
the parents ask for permission you know
and maybe they can talk to your parents
maybe you guys can talk talk to some of
the friends that they know find out
which community they are involved in you
know it's restore you don't just go find
some off the internet say hey I guess
why does get marry gotta keep your
family involved exactly so I get family
Bob and you never know who's on the
internet and that's why it's important
but I found my wife halfway around the
world and I can find one in my local
community and if it wasn't for the
internet there's no way I would have
found her yeah you just got to be
careful always ask Allah be connected to
you later to make it easy and to protect
you exactly yeah so any closing comments
and suggestions for those single people
out there that you know what they can
relate to what we're saying they just
need a little extra help extra push yeah
you hit right there on the spot I mean
it's not easy the whole marriage thing
is very difficult for all of us all of
us you know even before you're married
you go through a certain type of
struggle after you get married you go
through a different type of struggle but
the whole life itself is a struggle it's
all a struggle and at the end it there
is that they will come an end and when
it comes to the end you just want your
good deeds to be better than your bad
deeds and you want your Creator to have
mercy on you and to give you success in
here after inshallah and that's it just
pray to Allah to make you strong to give
you patience and inshallah hopefully and
show it will be successful for you
inshallah half our Deen have fardeen
khan inshallah jazakallah ha thank you
very much for Michael this is a closer
friend lighting me well yeah thank you
for being with us and I could thank you
for tuning in to another episode of a
Dean show you got to hear it here we're
trying to give you that sassy advice to
get motivated to find that special
person to be with never exclude your
family always have them involved
in this process your Imam somebody who's
there with you helping you but the most
important thing is that you have that
connection with your Creator and you're
always beseeching his help inshallah
everything will be all right with that
said we look forward to seeing you next
week here on the Dean show until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you the
dvds for Dawa as allah has said in the
Quran in surah now 16 125 will do elasa
be laid up bookable hikmah to invite all
to the way of your lord with wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best and this is a
great opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world islam submission
to the one god let's see what everyone's
talking about you find one contradiction
it can't be from God but the rational
idea the rational explanation is you do
your best give up for spring guidance I
will never give up spending this message
okay you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now if you say
that you're not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of this nun you
cannot be a Muslim is that ended our
faith too it's cold it's Leigh everybody
sleeping I arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see hola you know
all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my sing tomorrow I'm seen for
slave you're my love alone I'm the one
runs away oh look I me